[Musique]
bienvenue à la ferme chez les deux
gourmands je suis l'un des deux
guillaume l'autre moment c'est lui mon
associé
[Musique]
je n'ai pas visité le tueur
bienvenue dans la boutique ici c'est ici
qu'ont commercialise tous nos produits
aux biscuits nos miel de bande et pis on
a fait des mises en avant pour les fêtes
parce qu'on vend plein de coffrets
pendant les périodes de fin d'année pour
tous ceux qui ont envie de se régaler
avec de bons produits locaux on n'a même
pas des piscines aux tablettes de
chocolat les produits partenaires des
jus des pattes du thé et aussi plein
d'autres choses des spiritueux derrière
on a un petit peu de produits frais les
glaces et enfin nos miel qu'on retrouve
ici et nos biscuits et maintenant on va
aller en fabrication vous faire
découvrir comment tout ça est fait donc
on est au coeur ici de la biscuiterie
c'est ici qu'on fabrique tous nos
produits nos biscuits et nos coûts qui
aujourd'hui qu'on retrouve à bord des
trains tgv inouïe donc on fait les
pesées ici ensuite on pétrit la pâte une
fois qu'on l'a pétri on va la façonner
on va donner la forme aux cookies on
dispose alors les cookies sur les
plaques mis sur des chariots on envoie
en cuisson et une fois que ses cuisses
suivez-moi
voilà à quoi
ça ressemble vous l'avez pas là mais ça
sent bon et c'est délicieux et ccoo qui
nous restent ensuite pour finir à les
mettre en sachet avant de les mettre
dans les cartons puis les expédier et en
sachet ça ressemble à ça